hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game that took place a few
minutes ago i wasn't really planning on
doing any more videos today but then
this game was brought to my attention by
an excellent subscriber
uh sam reddick so thank you for that uh
it was played
in a simultaneous exhibition uh
nishigiri held it was um
an exhibition for the winners of the
optiver warwick tournaments
and he faced five opponents here and
this is one of those games
as usual giri is uh white in all of the
games and the players get 10 minutes
plus 10 seconds increments so it's a
sort of a rapid game
but giveaway does get the extra 40
minutes because he has to play on all of
the boards and he
of course is uh losing time uh
regardless of
which board he is currently facing so
it's a really nice game really strong
game i do not know who the gentleman
he's facing is he goes by the name of
the simpsons nerd 42 on unleashes and he
doesn't have any additional
uh info on him but he's raided at least
on leeches around i think somewhere 22
2200. uh so without further ado let's
check it out
and uh and let's see what happened here
uh so gary has the white pieces as he
does on all boards and opens the game
with
e4 that we have e5 by uh i don't know
how to refer
let's refer to him as the nerd so uh mr
nerd goes e5 we have knight to f3
uh knight to c6 and bishop to b5 the
geary opts for the
royal lopez we have a6 morpheus defense
and the bishop to a4
knight to f6 black continues development
and here
we have castles and this is a very
standard idea interestingly i did find
uh one game in 2004 where king the f1
was played also
documented in the database but it was an
online event so i imagine this was a
mouse slip
so here uh castles by geary and bishop
to a7 just continuing development
uh we have d3 gary goes for the martinez
variation of the royal opus and now
b5 attacking the bishop bishop to b3 and
d6 so both players
are playing very strong uh and they're
both
very backed by by theory uh we have
a3 uh and here comes castles by black we
have knights to c3
so again both players just continuing
development and bishop to g4 makes sense
d3 was played bishop is here so it does
make sense to pin this knight
with bishop to e3 by geary and now
knight to d4
putting pressure on the knight here and
if you don't want to mess up your pawn
structure in front of your king you
absolutely have to capture this knight
so bishop captures e captures
and now knights the d5 and this position
has been reached a lot of times uh
uh in uh games of all levels in top tier
games it was also reached a lot of times
i will just mention some of the games
uh it was uh played in in uh for example
anish giri had it against the dingle
iran
in 2018 in in the in shenzhen they drew
that game uh maxim varsha lagrave had it
twice against lebanon in the defeated
world cup in philisi
in 2017 uh caruana had it against arun
in the london chess classic of 2017
uh but also interestingly uh giri
himself had it against the ding yeah
okay we
i already mentioned that uh but it was
probably the game
that mr nerd here was going for when
when he was
going for this line as he prepared
something different
so here uh in all of the games uh well
not even all of them but c5 is a known
move in top tier games and also knight
captures on d5 but here
c6 was played and this is uh uh well
a rather strange move and the gear here
goes for
knight to f4 and already uh it's hard to
say if gary was surprised here because
this move is known to theory and uh
it's hard to hard to pick one
grandmaster that's better prepared than
a niche gear here
uh but h3 seems to be the the way to go
here for example h3
and now we trade everything off captures
first knight captures with czech bishop
captures and then queen characters
so this is what should um kind of should
be played and
white is a little bit better here black
has the messed up pawn structure
and the white will always have the
advantage but here uh gary played for
a different uh variation he played
knight to f4
and now uh well now it gets
really interesting here uh you should go
d5
this position has been reached before
and d5 was played in all of the games
uh but here yeah instead giri goes for
knight to
h5 and now what do you play here uh
sorry black goes for knights to h5 so
what do you play here
uh the knight is under attack uh
obviously if you capture this nightwood
knight captures an h5
bishop captures and then this pin
remains here so it's very unpleasant for
white
so gary instead after this knight h5
move goes h3 and he forces a favorable
trade
uh knight captures on f4 and now h
captures on g4 and he messed up his pawn
structure a little bit
but he has a very very interesting plan
he has a beautiful bishop here cutting
uh
across this entire diagonal he wants to
play g3
uh kick away the snipe play king g2 and
then use the h file for the rooks the uh
to attack the black king so here c5
uh preparing at some point to push c4
first we're going to have to defend the
c4 square one more time
most likely with rook to c8 and now gary
kicks away
uh the the knight with g3 and now knight
back to g6 knight the e6
also uh also playable uh black prefers
knight to g for king
a knight h3 check doesn't really do
anything just king here and the knight
is
uh really in in a tough spot
if you go back with knight to g5 uh just
knight captures bishop captures and now
f4 and this is just
this is just terrible uh for for uh for
black those pawns are
incredibly strong and the rooks will
just be doubled up on the h file and so
on
so here instead after g3 like we said
knight goes back to g6 and now we have
king to
g2 so ready to bring the rooks over to
the h file
queen to d7 now attacking the g4 pawn of
course uh giri
uh not about to allow this goes knight
to h2 he defends the the g4 pawn
uh we have rooked the c8 now preparing
this c4 idea and now giri of course
plays bishop to d5 he doesn't want to
weaken his uh weaken his bishop and
allow c4 to get the bishop trapped
so here rook f the e8 and again it's uh
it's hard to find an active move for
black here but
um uh for example bishop to d8 could be
played
but it's a very very ugly move to uh to
have to play but it still keeps an eye
on the g5 square which
which is kind of kind of a big deal but
here rook after e8 was played and now
gary just continues with his plan
rook to h1 that's not an h1 uh
rook to h1 uh and here uh we have bishop
to f8
uh it's an ugly square but at least now
the rook gains access to the
uh to the e file maybe you can play uh
rook to e5 maybe this can prevent the
queen from reaching h5 at some point
so it's all very interesting but it's
still uh for example bishop to d8 still
keeps an
eye on the on the g5 square but after g5
uh white can still play this if bishop
captures you're just going to bring the
queen to h5
and now this is being threatened as the
rook is here and also the bishop is
threatened so it's it's just a very very
ugly position
if bishop h6 blocking this then just
knight g4 again goes after the bishop
and if you go for some tricky lines for
example bishop f4
trying to get a nice fork here white
will just ignore you just the knight the
g4 put pressure here and that's uh
very very hard to defend if at all
possible you can never play h6 to
prevent
queen captures on h7 because well the
bishop is still here just queen captures
and g6 and the white has a
winning advantage uh so that well that's
all very interesting after rook to h1
bishop to f8 was played instead and now
gary just continues of course he needs
to make way for his queen to reach the
h5 square g5 was played and now
knights the e7 uh trying to eliminate
one of the attackers here
and here if this was a very very serious
game gear you would of course move the
bishop uh
you do not want to allow this capture
but now for the moment you will have to
trap your own bishop here on a2 but it's
not a problem because
uh after queen to h5 the the this is not
very strong at some point you will be
able to break it and then you can
continue playing knight
to g4 maybe double up rooks and the h
file and so on
however here after knight a7 geary does
not move the bishop rider he jumps
in the attack immediately with queen to
h7
and now he asks black what do you want
to do and here black should most
definitely capture the bishop
and the game continues we're going to
have knight g4 threatening checkmate and
after this is defended only then would
anish
grab the knight on d5 and we have this
position where white is
white is definitely better and you know
good things are probably going to happen
however after gyrus queen to h5 uh black
did not capture the bishop
mr nerd went for g6 and here
uh well this simply does not work for
black here white has a really really
strong move
which i'm pretty sure you know what it
is but just in case uh feel free to
pause the video here
and win the game for a niche while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
idea as we did mention in the beginning
that
uh this whole thing uh was kind of about
the the queen sacrifice and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is of course
queen captures on h7 and well it seems
like uh
it's hard to to really pinpoint what's
going on it's uh
uh it's actually a really really
crushing so king captures queen is the
only move here
and now of course knight the g4 with a
discovered
check and here black played king to g7
and he allowed gary a very swift
swift victory uh because now there there
is no defense i will however
show what happens if black goes for the
absolute best defense and that's
bishop to h5 trying to give up even more
material but at least you free up some
squares for your king but it's still
it's still winning for white but it's
very interesting so i'm gonna show it
uh rook captures with czech king g7 and
now
knight to f6 threatening of course the
rook h7 check king of faith in rook
captures on f7 checkmate
so here uh it doesn't really matter what
you play
uh you could go for uh if you try to
save your queen with queen to d8 that
obviously doesn't work it's just mating
too like we mentioned rook h7 checking
f8
and rook captures here with checkmate uh
so you would have to offer the queen
back you'd have to go for knight
captures on d5
and only now do we capture the queen but
not just yet first rook h7
for safety with check king f8 and now
we're gonna grab the queen
with check king to e7 we're going to
play e captures on d5 and after king
captures on d7 it seems like the
material is kind of equal because both
players have
both rooks but white's position is
simply too dominant rook captures on f7
with
check and there's just not not a good
move here uh
if if you go king to d8 then you're
completely cut off the pawn prevents the
king from going anywhere else if you go
here then
rook the h1 followed by rook to h7 is
deadly so you'd have to trade here and
after captures capture so let's say
rookie
rookie one check and now it doesn't
matter king f7
rook the e6 is a beautiful outpost for
for the white rook and black doesn't
have
any counter play here white will just
play f4 bring the king into the game
and slowly but surely you know have a
have a very enjoyable game
black doesn't even have any counter play
with this because he still has to tend
to the
d6 spawn with moves like rook to d8 so
this is completely lost for black
but black did not find such a resilient
way to continue the game
instead black played king to g7 and now
of course
it's completely winning for white knight
to f6
threatening checkmate white's position
is so strong here that
if anish wanted to he could have just
played rook to h7 check first uh just
for
for fun uh to sacrifice even more
material because after this
rook the h1 check king here we can still
play
sorry after this knight to f6 check king
here and rook to h1
we still get the exact same threat of
rook to h7 checkmate and there's no way
to defend
but giri of course uh is obligated to
finish the game as soon as possible as
you always should
so after this king to g7 he played
knight to f6 and now there is no defense
against the rook to h7
checkmate his opponent uh probably
wanted
the game to last a little bit longer
maybe not to be classified as a
miniature who knows
he played queen to h3 check gary of
course said thank you very much and
after knight to f5
uh giri just delivered the finishing
touch and that's a rook to h7 checkmate
so really really awesome stuff uh and um
it really shows you how little it takes
for for great positions to happen and
for such a game to exist
because his opponent played extremely
well uh up until this point uh
that we mentioned like uh sorry let me
just
rewind a little bit uh right up until
this point this
like i said this position has been
reached in so many games and especially
so many top tier games
you know uh between uh the the world
elite
and he even prepared a little surprise
for geary and then the game uh started
to get get really interesting but uh he
he definitely came prepared for this
simultaneous exhibition
and it uh was was a very very enjoyable
game
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it thank you again very much
samurai for uh suggesting this game
that's why it's very important to use
hashtag suggestion on any social media
like i said this was suggested to me on
twitter
uh and gary won all of the games so all
of the five games it's
five five to zero in gary's favor so
congratulations on that
uh i would like to thank brandon wade uh
douglas curl and
nathan uh bakugen a mystery person and
benjamin fraim for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day